hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to bendy in the a machine
chapter 2 now I want to apologize first
by this late video I know things got off
to a bad start today I'd like my
computer's just explode on me and then I
had to go to a meeting and then I had
record Bob way and Jack and so I only
just now was able to record which is
like an hour before you see this video
but either way this game came out I'm
ready to play it and I know the last one
left off with Vandy chasing you after
you turned on the egg machine Howie I
don't know you got hit in the head by
goofy well I guess there's only one
thing to do
press on see if I can find a way out
hell yeah I get the ax still yeah oh
yeah Oh what happens if you didn't pick
up the ax would you just go on your
daily life and look at this horrible
monstrosity oh my god is that from the
ink machine alright oh yeah I walked in
here and then I got knocked out but two
of the oh my god it's chapter two so two
of these symbols are activated oh yeah
yeah okay so anyway hello is yeah I
didn't actually expect an answer from
that those more of a general hello just
announcing my presence
rhetorical hello just like all my hellos
he will set us free will he do that is
this a sacrifice to him also what is
that it's a bowl of eggs and ball of
bones like it so big I don't know how
did this place get so inky yeah
I pray you hear me mm-hmm yes I still
are coming to save me and I will be
swept into your final loving embrace no
no I refuse absolutely not
Sammy can I get a name whoa that was not
my voice was that my voice who said that
who the hell said that to me you bendy I
will not give you an a man with all
these satanic symbols you're the savior
of dick that's who you are
hey huh Oh didn't know that work oh yeah
okay that didn't work
ah ah it's it's sweet embrace all over
the floor
god damn it Brandi clean up after
yourself oh yeah oh yeah
excuse me couldn't you help me by I met
that hello I'm sorry hello were you
carrying how did he go I didn't even
look oh so busy chip shopping now I feel
like an [ __ ] who is that
why is bandy have bacon soup yeah
already done idiot powers this gate
somehow mmm should be a couple switches
in your body then maybe I can open
redirect power to the gate find three
switches okay I got my eyes open this
time except this Court is gonna get it
and then you're gonna get it whoever's
out there same with this board yeah yeah
yeah yeah
okay so there should be switches around
here but I don't recall seeing any
switches on the way oh I did I did see
switches Oh so we're gonna go on another
hunt are we well I got one good for me
oh [ __ ] I ate that I don't know if
that's this is a good idea okay I'm a
musical genius but what's the point of
that yeah it better not be a switch
hunting beside no board okay I got a bad
feeling about eating that bacon soup
because I think that was supposed to
give me some health back but I don't
know why I'd need it unless there was
got to be some sort of monster that was
going to be hurting me is that the only
thing that I could imagine for the needy
surfers gets held back unless it's just
all ink inside that bottle and then
that's no good
oh yes rained down upon me your blessing
just acts the [ __ ] out of you oh now I'm
the one with power maybe what happens if
I eat all the things Wow
take some of that branch bye Kenny oh
yes I can look look bug
oh thank you there's another one look
it's a little greedy for me to be eaten
all this soup by myself but what else am
I gonna do I'm lonely
plug okay that's all that there look
look I got it all inside my belt a bee
yeah don't do that to me okay oh yeah
okay huh oh [ __ ] you yeah that's how
it's gonna be pop up mmm huh come on do
a 360 whirlwind
oh yeah musky relic 360 no-scope
point huh can I do a 720 am i sick
enough ah yeah I made it think I nailed
that one
oh I see you Wow you were hard to find
good god man they really hide these
things obscurely in this game I don't
know why they did the same thing with
the other items that I had to find in
the last game but at least it's only
three of these I was wandering around
for a long time last time but let's
carry on I've got things to axe in the
face
hello goofy
all righty then hi who and how and you
are yeah hey yo hey ha 360 scrap mist
nailed it
got it hello I'm in the music department
that sounds delightful and happy and fun
why wouldn't I like that look how happy
bandy is in the rain in ink training ink
don't know why the lighter side of hell
well you know oh I didn't expect that to
open hello hello oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy
[Music]
are you going to go to the places where
you're being worshiped and sacrificed to
because that's where Bendis at
I'm a genius okay alright then that
didn't do me any service so I'm guessing
what I'm gonna have to do is I'm gonna
have to come back here and then I'm
going to collect all these musical
pieces somebody bumpy I'm in the demon
no they're all called lighter side of
hell that's a little ominous okay I'm
gonna go now I'm gonna go away I wanna I
want to screw myself and have a nice day
take the advice I always give to
everybody looks like the stairwell is
flooded I'm gonna get out of here I need
to find a way to dream it is there a
built-in rain to this why would there be
a built-in drain into a staircase I mean
I I wasn't quite an engineer but I know
enough about building standards that
usually stairways are built with
built-in pumps to drain ink and cuz no
standard water pump would be able to
drain ink as well it'd have to be custom
designed for that oh I don't know what
that did but it didn't do anything I'm
gonna stop questioning reality here and
Oh angel she sings and she dances
[Music]
good here we go okay
I know what to do I'm mr. drew aren't I
and now what I remember okay hey how's
it going bendy Jesus all right so I got
a run from there
Oh what the [ __ ] underwater lumen behind
me Oh God [ __ ] hell the [ __ ] with
that was I can't get in here [ __ ]
what
see that geez me ass [ __ ] I can't get in
there was that okay so this she's oh hi
hello
your new long have you been there are
you not down here anymore I guess see in
there
[ __ ] oh hi oh okay that's normal
I'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you when
I get my axe in your place I got [ __ ]
up [ __ ] doors don't do it hey hey stop
it stop it alright [ __ ] stop it stop
it stop
oh god you're so [ __ ] weird dah dah
by my die I'm gonna die don't my god
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you oh yeah oh yeah I
can't handle me
god only I had more soup to drink wait
there's more of them down there
Elle is happening and I'm gonna go back
down again apparently because it's
something oh sorry I ran away I just
wanted to see what was happening oh the
three are up there now okay I see how
this is okay I'm gonna go listen to the
thing apparently because you guys are
being a bunch of [ __ ] sneaking on me
[Music]
yeah they don't I don't know what
Sammy's doing was it wait this wasn't
here before
hello where was this bleeding bat okay
oh hi how long have you been there okay
little weird little weird not gonna lie
a little weird a little bendy do not let
Joey see this okay okay all right
ooh something wrong happening here
Sammy Lawrence music department director
is the pumps buggy but that's one hell
of a least blocking the door though what
I could just stop flowing can get in
what do you mean that's yeah then why
did you record yourself saying it and
leave it in the middle of the hallway
it's time to believe I don't know what
to believe in anymore what the [ __ ] was
that
I heard that well I heard that oh I
heard that so I gotta find something in
a garbage can is that what I heard
correctly so it's got to be in one of
these garbage cans right maybe alright
so I guess it's time to go a-hunting
again whoa whoa whoa whoa caught you
right in the giblet Jabbar [ __ ]
douche are you doing also why is the ink
coming alive because that's something
that shouldn't be Avenue I'm gonna get
you you kid
get out of here think about it I'm just
backtracking this way because there are
garbage cans over here so I just need to
make sure it wasn't in none of these Oh
got it
okay Gotti hello okay so I got that and
that's good so now I can unlock this
supposed closet and find out whatever's
in there even though supposedly my
characters worked here before knows
everything about this blog blog blog
love me some bacon soup blog it's pretty
sanctuary Joey Drew has his and I've got
mine to enter you need only know my
favorite song the banjo playfully clucks
the banjo once again
strums its melody the violin shudders
with a piercing voice the violin again
screams sing my zone and my sanctuary
okay banjo banjo violin violin I'm
guessing that was supposed to be
randomly generated don't do it don't do
it don't do it but with your stupidity
you have revealed your secrets to me so
I think I got to go up and I got to
start the movie and then banjo banjo
vile vile and then I'll be good to go
then I'll know exactly what I need to do
oh there's five of you now great great
great love that anti banjo violin violin
Benjamin you violin violin okay weird a
banjo
[Music]
hey I got it open for me Oh boom
well that seems ominous I think I should
do this if I'm turning this [ __ ] on
that's bad okay good no more ink
machines to turn on here hey [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you I think those an
appropriate mrs. Clark hi goddamnit
[ __ ] off ah Thank You mr. M ow [ __ ]
out out stop stop God you better not you
better not have
no no [ __ ] you okay so now hopefully oh
[ __ ] off with you [ __ ] off with you [ __ ]
off with you okay one at a time please
one at a time one at a time hey one at
time what was it hello one at a time
please one at a time mmm mmm all right
did I bat them did I BAM good bat how
about one more BAM
yeah yeah professional BAP are over here
known as markiplier gonna wrap you in
the next century okay anyway we got it
so flagging it through here
not that it was necessary path you okay
we're good we're good
um okay what is that the thing machine
yeah a machine mark - oh well I don't
seem good I don't know why we need that
much ink but okay here we go [ __ ] so
we've just got to get out of here
I I have words about that same system
but I'll get to that when I get out of
here looking again in the back of my
skull again okay thank you yeah okay all
right then again again there we go now
nice and tight oh we wouldn't want our
sheep Wilma now would we
maybe we would we wouldn't we might I
must admit I am honored you came all the
way down here to visit me okay
it almost makes what I'm about to do
seem cool okay
but the believers must honor their
Savior I must have him notice me okay
you notice me you who cool you're to me
for that face yeah I been here before
now for our Lord is calling to us my
little sheep the time of sacrifice is at
hand
okay and then I will finally be free
from this prison this inky dark abyss I
call my body I like my body I don't know
why your body is all blackened quiet
listen I can hear him crawling above you
let us not must be complete it doesn't
need to that's not a requirement soon
she will hear me he will set us free
will he hear me screaming
maybe all right bye nice feet you loser
okay so what do I do about this what do
I do
I see my axe okay whew that is an option
okay no thank you
nobody Joe let me go
okay okay here we go fine no god dammit
don't do that to me don't you [ __ ] do
that to me
bap bap bap bap [ __ ] back get back
where are you're not bopping talking
hell tap tap clap clap clap ah [ __ ]
hey oh my god oh my god oh my god okay
alright then okay thank you thank you
huh I'm still running I think I'm still
in trouble I think oh I know you're in
here
come on show yourself and I don't think
that's a good idea
hello hello hi goofy okay Boris also
known as okay comes out weird so anyway
that is the end of chapter 2 so the same
system if you're gonna kill the player
don't make them backtrack 20 minutes to
get back to where they were that's all
nothing about it other than that this is
actually getting really really
interesting I like it a lot and there's
still a lot of potential here now in
this one there were enemies I could use
a little more work but it was a bit more
threatening in this one and I like that
a bit more than the ambiguous darkness
but either way that is all the time that
after this episode I still have
laryngitis like I've still been fighting
it that's what has been making my voice
so weak so I've been trying not to
strain it but thank you everybody so
much for watching we'll be back on
schedule very soon
and thanks again and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]
oh hello uh oh
after credit sequence or not I guess
okay bye